water the wellspring of life we've dealt
with a number of anomalous water sources
on this channel like
scp-006 the much sought-after fountain
of youth or the terrifying
scp-3280 where murderous water threatens
to destroy the entire world but we've
never seen anomalous water that behaves
quite like this before in many of the
legends of king arthur the sword of
excalibur is presented to him by the
mystical lady of the lake this lady
emerges from the depths of the water
gifting arthur with the enchanted sword
it's an incredible if impossible image a
woman appearing from within the lake
rising up from the bottom and breaking
through the surface it's safe to say
that none of us have ever seen anything
quite like it well at least most of us
haven't in a small unnamed english
village there was a young woman who set
out on a particularly lovely warm spring
day to take a swim in a nearby lake
while waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange ripple ghost
across the surface she stopped her
swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this lady of
the lake reaching out her own hand of
flesh and bone to touch this impossible
creature
just as her fingertips reached the water
woman's own the figure dissolved back
into the lake with a splash the young
woman ran home telling anyone who would
listen about the incredible thing she
had seen that day of course no one
believed her that is until word of her
sighting reached the only people who
might take her claim seriously the scp
foundation they sent operatives to the
lake where they managed to capture the
shape-shifting entity dwelling there
scp-054 also known as the water nymph is
a being made up entirely of water with
an average volume of 90 liters when it
is out of a body of water the being
tends to adopt the appearance of a
humanoid woman though it is capable of
taking on a variety of other shapes
including other humanoids animals and
various inanimate objects the entity is
also capable of shedding its form and
effectively disappearing into a given
body of water in order to avoid
shrinking or possibly disappearing
entirely from evaporation
scp-054 is required to return to a
larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its
version of a body revealed that it is
made up of ordinary water there is no
apparent reason for its ability to move
and no thermal electromagnetic
biological or supernatural anomalies
were detected the research team could
not determine what might make this water
alive and sentient and the nature of its
unusual properties is uncertain to this
day when scp-054 was first brought into
containment at site-08 it displayed
surprisingly congenial and curious
behavior often walking around outside of
the water and taking turns mimicking the
shapes of various staff and scientists
that spoke to it its demeanor began to
shift towards suspicion and aggression
however following a series of
experiments and an incident involving
the research staff the first experiment
conducted on scp-054 sought to determine
what would happen if the entity was
denied access to any fresh water water
was drained from the fountain holding it
leaving only enough water for it to form
a humanoid shape but no additional water
in the base and to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time
scp-054 became visibly frustrated as the
water was being drained out of its
enclosure for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
fountain it became distant and even
called to anyone who attempted to speak
to it zero five four only became
friendly again once the water in its
fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test
scp-054's reaction to extreme
temperatures particularly extreme cold
the temperature of the containment
facility was slowly dropped until the
room fell below the freezing point of
water as the temperature dropped zero
five four became sluggish and exhausted
it lost its ability to shift between
forms remaining locked in its preferred
humanoid female shape its movements
slowed more and more as the room grew
colder until the entity was completely
frozen solid portions of the ice were
chipped off and studied revealing the
crystals were identical to those of
ordinary ice after the subzero testing
the research team decided to take things
to the other end of the spectrum and
test the effects of heat on scp-054
the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment and its
temperature was slowly raised over the
course of several minutes when the water
reached a temperature of 95 degrees the
entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls
of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous calm and cooperative nature of
scp-054 was nowhere to be found this
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this
newfound resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
dr seskel the acting head of the
research team conducted a study
involving
scp-054's memory and ability to be
conditioned the entity was presented
with a series of increasingly complex
mazes and puzzles when it failed to
comply with the experiment or solved a
puzzle incorrectly the entity was
punished with an electrical shock or the
release of silica gel into its body both
of these options seemed to cause it a
great deal of pain and distress and it
was eager to avoid further exposure to
them
scp-054 displayed impressive learning
and problem-solving capabilities
revealing it is likely much more
intelligent than it was first presumed
to be dr cesco observing the experiments
and with the effectiveness of his
somewhat unsavory motivational
techniques equipped to his research
assistant that they would have it
trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48-hour rest period before
experimentation was resumed yet again
this time dr seskel planned to expose
scp-054's water source to various levels
of acids and bases in order to test its
homeostatic capabilities beginning with
a 0.5 m solution of hydrochloric acid
prior to conducting the experiment dr
seskel noted i have no idea what will
happen but if this thing incorporates
homeostatic mechanisms like i suspect
then we should get some insight into how
it maintains its form he also noted that
scp-054's behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned
scp-054 displayed a now familiar
reluctance when it was removed from its
containment chamber and taken to the lab
it thrashed around in the fountain
splashing researchers with water and
retreated from them as they approached
in spite of its efforts however it was
removed from its fountain and placed in
the experimental tank the solution of
hydrochloric acid was then dripped into
the tank and then all hell broke loose
as soon as the acid touched the surface
of its water
scp-054 became incredibly distressed it
formed into the shape of a human face
eyes wide mouth open in a silent scream
of rage and pain the water churned so
aggressively that the lid of the tank
was shaken loose allowing it to escape
the boundaries of its containment the
water formed into two large hands which
shot out of the tank and grabbed the two
nearest researchers pulling them into
the water and exposing their skin to the
acid now present there as the men
scrambled to drag themselves back out of
the tank and their colleagues were busy
helping them
scp-054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment facility
the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns
on their skin as well as significant
mental distress they were given
immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on scp-054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of dr cesco 054's object
class was changed to euclid
scp-054 is currently contained in a
watertight isolation room fitted with
climate control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entity's
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area must wear
nbc suits while inside and must spend 10
minutes isolated in a drying room after
exiting before they are permitted to
return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the
entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis and kept at optimal levels
for the health of scp-054
during the course of its containment
following the incident around the
acid-base incorporation experiment 054
has developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep scp-054 calm
no male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because five years have passed since the
last incident involving
scp-054 its object class has been
changed from euclid to safe on the
recommendation of the lead researcher
assigned to its case of course caution
should still be exercised while
interacting with the entity this is the
scp foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown experimentation on scp-054
has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate the
entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself now go check
out scp-173 the sculpture and scp-682
the hard-to-kill reptile for more
enigmatic entities of the scp foundation